fascinating to think about you know
there being all of these ideas kind of
swimming you know almost with the noise
all around the world that all the
different generations and then some kind
of nonlinear thing happens where they
percolate up and and capture the
imagination of the mainstream and that
seems to be what's happening with AI now
I mean Nietzsche who you mentioned had
the idea of the Superman right but he he
didn't understand enough about
technology to think you could physically
engineer a Superman by piecing together
maliki molecules and in a certain way he
he was a bit vague about how how the
Superman would appear but he was quite
deep at thinking about what the state of
consciousness and the mode of cognition
of a Superman would be he was a very
astute analyst of you know how the human
mind constructs the illusion of a self
how it constructs the illusion of free
will how it constructs values like like
good and evil out of its own you know
desire to maintain and advance its own
organism he understood a lot about how
human minds work then he understood a
lot about how posthuman Minds would work
I mean this Superman was supposed to be
a mind that would basically have
complete root access to its own brain
and consciousness and be able to
architect its its own its own value
system and inspect and fine-tune are all
of its own its own biases so that's a
lot of powerful thinking there which
then fed in and sort of seeded all of
postmodern continental philosophy and
all sorts of things have been very
valuable in the development of culture
and indirectly even even of technology
but of course without the technology
there it was all some quite abstract
thinking so now now we're at the time in
history when a lot of these ideas can be
can be made real which is amazing
amazing and scary right it's kind of an
interesting to think what do you think
Nietzsche would Dave he was born a a
century later or transported through
time what do you think you would say
about AI I mean those are quite
different if he's born a century later
or transported through time well he be
they'd be on like tick-tock and
instagramming you would never write the
great works he's written so yes
transporter baby maybe also sprach
zarathustra would be a music video I
mean I mean yeah but if he was
transported through time do you think it
that they'd be interesting actually to
go back you just made me realize that
it's possible to go back and read
Nietzsche with an eye of is there some
thinking about artificial beings I'm
sure there he has inked he had Inklings
I mean with Frankenstein before him I'm
sure he had Inklings of artificial
beings somewhere in the text it'd be
interesting to see to try to read his
work to see if he hadn't if if Superman
was actually an AGI system like if you
had Inklings of that kind of thinking he
didn't he didn't know I would say no I
mean he had he had a lot of Inklings of
modern cognitive science which are very
interesting if you look in like the the
third part of the collection that's been
tunneled the will to power I mean an in
book three there there's there's very
deep analysis of thinking processes but
he he wasn't so much of a physical
tinkerer type type guy it was very
abstract and
you